meet  scp-2662 also known as cthulhu believe  us he's really not what you're expecting  the primary anomalous effect of cthulhu  is warping the minds of random civilians  out there in the world and causing them  to independently form highly dangerous  and depraved cults these cults will do  everything they can to break into the  low-security humanoid wing where  scp-2662 is contained in an attempt to  free him and also perform depraved blood  and sex rituals in his name the scp  foundation has consistently been unable  to stop them getting in the problem is  at only a few hundred years old cthulhu  is practically a teenager by his own  standards he isn't interested in joining  any of these cults and in fact finds  them pretty creepy and disgusting he  submitted himself for foundation  containment voluntarily and they keep  him safe from the weirdos who worship  him